a public charter school in henderson is
expanding to include k
through fall through 5 excuse me this
fall this is at slam academy near 95 in
russell
the campus already welcoming middle
school and high school students
madison kimbrough went to the school and
spoke to teachers parents and students
about what is a new expansion
a tuition-free public charter school is
expanding this fall
slam sports leadership and management
will be opening a k-5 facility
right next door to their current campus
in henderson what's unique about slam is
its ability to teach the standard
curriculum
while incorporating sports whenever
applicable we
follow all of the state guidelines
and we offer a comprehensive classes for
all grade levels k through five but we
just infuse sports and athletics where
we can to make it more fun and more
relevant for the students they are
currently accepting applications for
their fall semester and parents like kim
kennedy have taken full advantage
she has one son in the seventh grade
already and plans on enrolling her
youngest son
this fall seeing how my oldest was able
to grow here and we he went to a couple
other charter schools in the valley as
well as a public school
so watching how he grew just in the
short time that he was here i feel like
starting my youngest at a younger age
may be more beneficial i like this
school way more than the other ones
the other ones don't really teach me as
much but these do slam will be adding
450 students through this edition
along with offering steam curriculum cte
programs
dual enrollment opportunities hands-on
learning and
leadership and character development
programs
slam has in-person learning four days a
week hopes to be back to full-time
in-person learning this fall you can
find more information
at 8newsnow.com